in the markets of Taiwan's capital city
Taipei you can find seemingly every
creature and it's not just choice meat
that's for sale but nearly every other
animal part as well
the Chinese sometimes complain their
countrymen will eat anything
very little is taboo and if there's one
Taiwanese gourmet who can turn the most
exotic fare into a delicacy fit for an
emperor it is chef ping Ching Cho mr.
Cho may be Taiwan's most highly
respected chef and tonight he will host
a very unusual dinner for some very
special guests including several of
taiwan's top food critics the dish he's
chosen to prepare is so taboo it may be
one of the few things many Chinese
refuse to eat the penis of the bull so
this was freshly killed today yes it was
killed this morning this is one entree
that challenges the diners and the
chef's alike if not prepared well the
meat is sinewy and tough and inside is
the Bulls urinary tract you have to cut
it open and wash it clean if you don't
then you'll have the taste of urine in
your food could this really be a meal
prized for centuries by Chinese emperors
traditionally it was considered a potent
aphrodisiac the Chinese version of
Viagra for help with his recipe chef Joe
is turning to his friend dr. Zen yearly
a specialist in Chinese medicine doctor
Lee knows exactly what combination of
herbs to prescribe to complement me is
bull penis more effective than viagra oh
yes as soon as it hits the tongue the
bull penis jump-starts the brain and
enhances the sexual desire I guarantee
we're going to make them very happy
chef Joe leaves the herbs to steep in
one pot while he stews the meat in
another it will take four hours to cook
for the Chinese a chef is like a doctor
and every meal is considered preventive
medicine here nearly every item is
believed to have a specific effect on
the body the Chinese believe that what
you eat is what you treat so if you eat
a pig's brain then you will treat a
human's brain likewise even a bully's
penis is thought to increase blood flow
to the genitals and boost a man's
stamina for sex people don't eat these
things every day you just couldn't take
it in his kitchen in Taiwan chef Cho is
finishing four hours of work and he's
ready to welcome his guests among them
are the leaders of Taiwan's premier
keulen Area associations men and women
who can make or break a chef's
reputation even for these experts this
meal will be a rare treat most of them
have never eaten bull penis before still
no one wants to be the first to dig in
even in Taiwan there are food taboos
that can make connoisseurs hesitate it's
a little scary but soon the verdict is
in it's just like eating a piece of beef
with tendons that is why chef Cho is so
great he was able to serve bull penises
in such a way that you can't tell which
part of the penis you're eating it's
high praise with his power to transform
the taboo into the tantalizing chef Cho
may win new converts to this ancient
delicacy diners who may seek it out not
just for its romantic and medicinal
effects but also for its taste